[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
und das sind einige der wichtigsten
themen von heute
ringen um die richtige strategie was
werden bund und länder ändern im kampf
gegen omikron
eskalation in kasachstan viele tote und
verletzte bei protesten in almaty
russland schickt truppen zur
unterstützung der regierung und
sorge und demokratie auf ein jahr nach
dem sturm aufs kapitol in washington
sind die usa tief gespalten
[Musik]
morgen wollen bund und länder über die
korona maßnahmen beraten doch schon
jetzt zeichnen sich konkrete
einzelheiten ab außerdem hat sich der
expertenrat der bundesregierung geäußert
die belegungszahlen in den
krankenhäusern seien in weiten teilen
des landes derzeit rückläufig aber so
die experten wegen der ausbreitung der
omicron variante brauche es zusätzliche
krisen vorkehrungen im gesundheitswesen
patricia wiedemeier
auch wenn ganz genaue zahlen zur
verbreitung der omicron variante immer
noch nicht vorliegen soll es morgen
erneut einen bund länder gipfel geben
ein neuer hausherr alte probleme und wie
so oft gibt es im vorfeld zahlreiche
vorschläge
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach zum
beispiel will die quarantäne zeiten für
personal in kritischen bereichen wie
krankenhäusern verkürzen
wir gehen in die richtung dass man eine
sehr sichere lösung hat gleichzeitig
aber auch die bereiche der kritischen
infrastruktur lebensfähigkeit das wird
erreicht indem man eben die quarantäne
dauer und auch die isolation dauer
verkürzt aber immer sicher stellt dass
durch einen pcr-test
gewährleistet ist niemand ist noch
anstecken so sieht die beschlussvorlage
der regierung zb für krankenhaus und
pflegeheim personal vor die quarantäne
von kontaktpersonen auf fünf tage die
isolation bei einer erkrankung auf
sieben tage zu verkürzen ein pcr test
ist verpflichtend in geschäften bus und
bahn wird dringend eine ffp zweimaster
empfohlen und ab dem 15 erstens soll der
zugang zur gastronomie nur noch mit 2 g
+ test oder booster erlaubt sein
vor allem die verkürzte quarantäne wird
in einigen ländern eher kritisch gesehen
jetzt seien erst mal konsequente kontakt
beschränkungen nötig das beste wäre
dieser notfall tritt nicht ein indem wir
alle unsere kontakte reduzieren indem
wir uns an die regeln halten wir sehen
dass wir auch mikron nicht unterschätzen
dürfen der bayerische ministerpräsident
söder erwartet morgen keine konkreten
ergebnisse von der runde zu ungenau sei
bisher die faktenlage
fragen wir chacon talabani in berlin
noch ist nichts beschlossen das alles
ist nur eine vorlage aber auf den ersten
blick ändert sich ja gar nicht soviel
oder ja wenn man den text liest der
morgen beraten werden soll dann ist das
wohl so der skizziert nämlich vor allem
die risiken die omikron wahrscheinlich
mit sich bringt basierend auf dem was
der expertenrat heute noch einmal gesagt
hat und verzichtet weitestgehend auf
größere verschärfung von maßnahmen wir
haben es gerade schon gehört die
datenlage ist unklar man weiß noch nicht
genau wie schlimm wird omicron
tatsächlich zu schlagen es ist von
milden verläufen die rede aber eben auch
von massenweisen ansteckungen und damit
auch großflächigen personal ausfällen
und man ist sich auch noch unsicher bei
der frage wie weit ist es schon
verbreitet es gibt eben noch
unklarheiten bei den zahlen aufgrund der
melde- lücken über die feiertage da muss
man noch ein paar tage abwarten bis man
tatsächlich belastbare zahlen hat das
alles fließt wahrscheinlich ein deswegen
ein relativ allgemeiner text mit wenigen
verschärfungen aber es ist ja auch noch
viel zeit für beratungen und und länder
wollen sich morgen ausreichend zeit
nehmen zunächst tagen die länder unter
sich ab 11 uhr und erst ab 13 uhr geht
es in die gemeinsame runde mit
bundeskanzler scholz und am ende des
nachmittags werden wir wahrscheinlich
sehen was dabei rauskommt genau morgen
mehr dazu dankeschön nach berlin tag und
hat
auch heute zeigt die kurve bei den
corona zahlen vom robert koch institut
weiter nach oben insgesamt wurden 64
1340 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
registriert 21 1570 mehr als vor einer
woche
443 todesfälle kamen dazu die
durchschnittliche sieben tage incidents
steigt deutlich auf 285 9
ebenso mit 51
1472 die zahl der insgesamt
nachgewiesenen omnicom fälle ein zuwachs
von 21 prozent im vergleich zum vortag
in italien liegt die inzidenz bei knapp
1500 deshalb für das land nun eine
impfpflicht für über 50 jährige ein
damit solle die funktionsfähigkeit der
kliniken erhalten werden sagt
ministerpräsident draghi ebenfalls ab
dem 15 februar dürfen über 50 jährige
nur zu ihrem arbeitsplatz wenn sie
geimpft oder genesen sind
jetzt nach kasachstan dort eskaliert die
lage was vor einigen tagen mit protesten
gegen hohe treibstoffpreise begann
mündete jetzt in gewalt und chaos mit
dutzenden toten und mehr als 1000
verletzten ein von russland geführtes
militärbündnis hat fallschirmjäger in
die ehemalige sowjet republik geschickt
die heftigsten ausschreitungen gab es
auch heute wieder in der stadt almaty im
südosten des landes axel sturm berichtet
schusswechsel vor dem rathaus zwischen
kasachischen soldaten und wie die
behörden sie nennen angreifern die
vergangenen stunden waren voller gewalt
in kasachstan es gab wohl dutzende tote
und mehr als 1000 verletzte sie müssen
verstehen hier wird etwas freigesetzt
nach 30 jahren schauen sie auf alle von
uns wurde geschossen aber niemand von
uns möchte jemanden verletzen oder unter
druck setzen
die proteste ursprünglich ausgebrochen
wegen preiserhöhungen beim flüssiggas
sind angewachsen auf eine dimension die
für kasachstans postsowjetische
geschichte einmalig ist und sie sind so
brisant dass russland zur hilfe
altpräsident tokarev hatte darum gebeten
die terroristischen banden stammen aus
dem ausland
deshalb habe ich heute die organisation
des vertrages über kollektive sicherheit
um unterstützung im kampf gegen diese
terroristische gefahr gebeten
russland schickt soldaten am morgen
schon brechen falsche mega auf über den
tag landen noch mehr einsatzkräfte in
kasachstan
für putin ist das wichtig er denkt so
stabilisiert er die lage auch in
russland und im gesamten
postsowjetischen raum
die lage an vielen orten im land bleibt
angespannt auch am abend
begann in moskau wer steht hinter diesen
protesten
der kreml und der kasachische präsident
die sagen es seien ausländische kräfte
die das land destabilisieren wollen das
ist etwas was wir aus dem kreml bei
jeder protestbewegung in einer ex
sowjetrepublik hören es ist also nichts
überraschendes genauso wenig
überraschend ist dass auf der anderen
seite diejenigen stehen die mutmaßen
russland könne doch da eine situation
provoziert haben diaz moskau jetzt
ermöglicht truppen zu schicken und
seinen eigenen einfluss auszubauen
belegbares belegbare beweise haben wir
weder für die eine noch für die andere
theorie es kann auch sein dass keine von
beiden stimmt denn das was wir sehen ist
dass abseits von den unruhestiftern die
polizisten attackieren oder
regierungsgebäude anzünden viele
menschen in kasachstan auf die straße
gehen und protestieren gegen ein regime
gegen ein autoritärer herrschaft die
seit jahrzehnten reichtum angehäuft und
in der eigenen machtclique verteilt hat
vielen dank nach moskau für diese
informationen für bürger
ein schwarzer tag in der geschichte der
usa jährt sich zum ersten mal der sturm
aufs kapitol in washington
am 6 januar 2021 drängen anhänger des
damaligen präsidenten jump mit gewalt in
das parlamentsgebäude ein dort wollten
sie verhindern dass die abgeordneten den
wahlsieg des demokraten joe biden
bestätigen fünf menschen kamen ums leben
zum marsch aufs kapitol hatte jobs
selbst aufgerufen weil ihm angeblich der
wahlsieg geklaut worden sei claudia
bates berichtet
das capitol friedlich herz der
amerikanischen demokratie sie hat
standgehalten einstweilen schweigeminute
im parlament präsident biden erinnert an
den tag an dem eine lüge die demokratie
ins wanken brachte
sind wir eine nation die nicht vom licht
der wahrheit lebt sondern im schatten
der lüge wir können es uns nicht
erlauben diese nation zu sein
die große lüge von der gestohlenen wahl
von 60 gerichten widerlegt von ihnen
hier geglaubt menschen aus der mitte der
gesellschaft wurden zu gewalttätern die
einen umsturz herbeiführen wollten von
präsident trump aufgewiegelt
wir gehen zum kapitol ihr holt euch euer
land nicht mit schwäche zurück ihr müsst
stärke zeigen und stark sein
der parlamentarische
untersuchungsausschuss hat bereits
hunderte zeugen gehört darunter
erschütternde aussagen von polizisten
wie micro verlor der hier vom mob
geschlagen und getreten wird einen
herzinfarkt erlitt
wir stecken jetzt bis zum hals in einem
kultur krieg das macht mir angst es gibt
viele die für richtig halten was da
passiert ist und die weiter auf gewalt
setzen um ihre politischen ziele zu
erreichen
so soll umsturz nicht mehr aussehen in
einigen republikanischen staaten werden
wahlgesetze geändert willfährige helfer
an verantwortliche stellen gesetzt der
angriff aufs kapital ist unsichtbar
geworden
der mrt wissen wie vor einem jahr vor
dem kapitol in washington
in welcher verfassung ist die demokratie
in den usa sind die wunden von damals
verheilt
im gegenteil die wunden vertiefen sich
noch deshalb hat präsident biden seinem
abgewählten amtsvorgänger heute
vorgeworfen dass er der amerikanischen
demokratie das messer an den hals legen
tatsächlich verbreiten donald trump und
seine helfer in medien und in der
politik weiter eben diese lüge von der
angeblich gestohlenen wahl und machen
stimmung die führung der
republikanischen partei schweiz
und deshalb wissen wir aus umfragen aus
neuesten umfragen dass etwa 30 prozent
der amerikaner darunter vor allen dingen
republikaner joe biden für einen
legitimen präsidenten halten rund acht
prozent halten gewalt für gerechtfertigt
um donald trump in sein amt wieder
einzusetzen und dessen anhänger
versuchen eben tatsächlich verschwörungs
gläubige in wichtige ämter hinein zu
setzen in denen sie dann über ablauf und
ergebnisse von wahlen mit entscheiden
die möglicherweise manipulieren und
deshalb sagen beobachter das ganze ist
so etwas wie ein schleichender umsturz
und eine große gefahr für die
amerikanische demokratie
dankeschön washington cathy wissen
ausführlich berichtet matti wissen bei
zdf heute live über das wasser hautnah
am kapitol erlebte um 19 uhr 30 auf zdf
heute.de und in unserer app
zurück nach deutschland
traditionell am 6 januar kommt die fdp
zum dreikönigstreffen zusammen aber
diesmal eben nicht als partei der
opposition sondern in
regierungsverantwortung
da gilt es die eigene klientel zu
bedienen ohne die koalitionspartner zu
verprellen und so warnt parteichef
lindner vor zu weitgehenden corona
beschränkungen und zur allgemeinen
impfpflicht sagt er da sei er noch
unentschieden aus stuttgart klaas
das ist der traditionelle jahresauftakt
der fdp wie üblich mit sternsingern und
auch ein jahresauftakt in krisenzeiten
was nicht nur der fast leere saal
deutlich macht sondern auch die
diskussion um eine allgemeine
impfpflicht die in der fdp heftig
umstritten ist
sie ist ein empfindlicher eingriff
in das selbstbestimmungsrecht der
menschen und deshalb ist das nur
natürlich und nachvollziehbar dass es
unterschiedliche abwägungen dazu gibt
während der parteichef wie er sagt nicht
mehr prinzipiell gegen eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ist haben andere erhebliche
bedenken je länger die diskussion geht
auch um die praktische umsetzung desto
eher wird klares eben eine allgemeine
impfpflicht kein allheilmittel ist eine
allgemeine impfpflicht gibt es große
verfassungsrechtliche und praktische
probleme konsequenter gesundheitsschutz
mit möglichst viel gesellschaftlicher
freiheit so umschreibt lindner heute die
fdp ziele in der korona politik er ist
insgesamt weniger angriffslustig als in
vergangenen jahren auf dieser bühne das
an der neuen rolle der fdp liegt statt
opposition nun als partei mit
regierungsverantwortung in einer
ampelkoalition in der kompromisse nötig
sind dennoch sei ihm wichtig die fdp
erkennbar bleibt auch als eigenständiger
faktor der politischen landschaft in
deutschland es dürfte ein spagat werden
nicht nur in der korona politik
die meisten von ihnen dürften es gemerkt
haben vieles wurde im vergangenen jahr
deutlich teurer die gesamtzahlen hat
jetzt das statistische bundesamt im
jahresschnitt
2021 klettere der die inflation auf
3,1 prozent so hoch wie seit anfang der
90er nicht mehr vor allem in den letzten
monaten stiegen die preise noch mal
deutlich im dezember lag die
teuerungsrate bei 5,3 prozent
das trifft besonders menschen mit
niedrigem einkommen
isabel de la vega
alle zwei wochen kommt theresa hierher
zur frankfurter tafel um lebensmittel zu
holen sie macht das noch nicht so lange
erst seitdem die preise für obst und
gemüse stark angestiegen sind früher
habe ich ungefähr
aber heute das ist mehr als 100 euro für
lebensmittel ist rauer geworden wir
kommen nicht klar theresa hat vier
kinder
sie macht eine ausbildung zur pflegerin
die inflation trifft menschen wie sie
besonders hart
unter inflation leiden natürlich
diejenigen die niedriges einkommen haben
diejenigen die ein hohes einkommen haben
die können das natürlich locker
kompensieren durch ersparnisse etc die
verbraucherpreise für nahrungsmittel
sind im dezember um 6 prozent gestiegen
für energie um über 18 prozent das
bekommen verbraucher und unternehmen zu
spüren bei stock im hessischen idstein
werden ultraleichte fahrräder in
handarbeit gefertigt die frachtpreise
für die komponenten haben sich
verzehnfacht diese fahrräder können gar
nicht ausgeliefert werde hier fehlen die
pedale weil sie in japan hergestellt
werden und container für den transport
fehlen also ein lieferengpass heißt dass
wir normalerweise drei bis sechs monate
vorlaufzeit haben jetzt aber sind das
zweieinhalb jahre im schlimmsten fall
die lieferengpässe wirken als
preistreiber zusätzlich zu den
energiekosten erst im frühsommer wird
sich die situation wieder ändern so
experten mindestens bis dahin also
bleiben steigende preise für unternehmen
und für verbraucher ein problem
sie war eine der letzten überlebenden
des holocausts hat sich unermüdlich für
versöhnung und respektvolles miteinander
eingesetzt nun ist ude simonsohn im
alter von 100 jahren gestorben
über ihre erfahrungen in mehreren
konzentrationslagern und über die
verbrechen der ns-zeit sprach sie seit
den 70er jahren vor allem mit jungen
menschen
2016 wurde sie ehrenbürgerin der stadt
frankfurt anbringen
und jetzt zur fußball bundesliga und dem
corona gebeutelten bayern wir haben
inzwischen neun infizierte spieler vier
weitere ausfälle kommen dazu und müssen
wohl doch morgen abend zum auftakt
spielt der bundesliga-rückrunde gegen
gladbach antreten kein grund für
münchens trainer nagelsmann so wörtlich
rum zu holen als auch noch all konzert
davis ausfiel wurde es eng für die
bayern denn von diesen elf spielern
stehen ihnen jetzt diese neuen krone
bedingt nicht zur verfügung dennoch sind
stand heute genug übrig um einen antrag
auf spielverlegung
aussichtslos zu machen denn selbst ein
leon goretzka der derzeit verletzt ist
zählt laut statuten wie ein gesperrter
spieler als spielberechtigt und wenn
mehr als 15 solcher akteure beisammen
sind muss gespielt werden vorausgesetzt
neun davon sind lizenzspieler heute war
das noch der fall
ich kümmere mich darum ja die
herausforderung aber reizvollen aufgabe
gerecht zu werden eine gute mannschaft
zu aufzustellen eine gute idee zu
entwickeln um gegen gladbach wo wir
sicherlich aufgrund des pokalspiels aber
aufgrund des liga auftakt des noch was
gutzumachen haben der in diesmal soll's
schon ein siegerlächeln seien nach
abpfiff
die deutschen tennis-herren haben beim
pick-up den einzug ins halbfinale
verpasst das team um olympiasieger
alexander schwere verlor in sydney knapp
gegen kanada mit 1 zu 2 ja einreisen
oder nach hause reisen tennis star novak
djokovic der sitzt in melbourne in einem
quarantäne hotel fest ob er an den
australian open teilnehmen darf das
entscheidet am montag ein gericht
unter staatlicher bewachung wird er da
abgeliefert wo normalerweise flüchtlinge
auf ihre ausweisung harten ist ein visum
ungültig drohte novak djokovic eine
dreijährige einreisesperre ob er eine
gültige medizinische ausnahmegenehmigung
besitzt muss geklärt werden bei seiner
einreise soll er jedoch dokumente von
tennis australia vorgezeigt haben und
erklärte zuvor auch eine genehmigung zu
besitzen regeln sind regeln novak
djokovic hatte keine korrekte
medizinische freistellung
diese freistellung für spieler und
mitarbeiter der australian open wurde 26
mal anonym beantragt und für wenige
bewilligt es gab auch fünf andere
spieler die menschen bekommen haben über
die wir die namen aber nicht kennen ein
gerichtsentscheid über seinen verbleib
soll es am montag in victoria geben
ja und gerade im gelände die
vierschanzentournee kobayashi sieg
gratulieren wir danke schön vorsicht
wenn sie morgens früh das haus verlassen
essen glatt werden denn heute nacht
ziehen von westen schnee und regen
wolken auf mehr dazu gleich von
katharina viertel vor zehn begrüßte
marietta slomka im heute-journal und wir
sind morgen sind wieder da danke für ihr
interesse und einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
an einem wirklich sonnigen donnerstag
heute vormittag gab es nur ein paar
letzte schneeschauer hier in
süddeutschland die schauer über der
nordsee die blieben doch meist über der
nordsee über großbritannien aber sehen
sie schon ein neues wolkenband und das
bringt uns in der zweiten nachthälfte
von westen schnee und regen bis zum
frühen morgen erreichen diese schnee und
regenfälle schleswig holstein und auch
das westliche rheinland pfalz machen sie
sich da auf glätte gefasst glatt kann es
aber auch sonst in deutschland werden
denn die temperaturen in dieser nacht
sinken auf plus 2 bis minus 13 grad
besonders kalt wird es über schnee am
alpenrand die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen ähnlich wie heute zwischen - 1
grad am alpenrand und 6 grad am
niederrhein und dieses schnee und regen
band zieht morgen im laufe des tages
weiter nach osten am nächsten freundlich
bleibt es noch hier zwischen dem
bayerischen wald und dem alpenrand es
bleibt glatt auf den straßen und hinter
schnee und regen lockern die wolken an
der nordseeküste auf da kann es dann
einige gewitter geben in der nacht zu
samstag und samstag über tag zieht an
ein kleines schnee und regen tief über
die mitte und den süden deutschlands und
auch der sonntag bringt viel schnee und
regen die neue woche fängt ruhiger an
guten abend